hey you guys what's up it's the movie
retrospective and we're we're doing
found footage today [ __ ]
which is not a genre i'm a big fan of
although i do actually
still like this movie although i will
say that
i kind of feel like
i appreciated it more back at the time
that it came out
because
the found footage genre hadn't been so
is wasn't so ubiquitous
and i really really liked the sort of
genius of the marketing behind it they
really kind of got in at exactly the
right time for this to just like blow up
and be like a huge cultural phenomenon
which is something i kind of want to
talk about because that's i find that
like really really interesting so now
you had never seen this before no i
never saw it but i do remember people
talking about it yeah it was a big it
was talking about it before it came out
yeah there was some confusion of whether
or not it was like a real paranormal
case they were talking about or if it
was
some kind of movie coming you'd you
would hear conflicting things and when
the movie came out
some people were still kind of confused
of whether or not it was real and kind
of like the damn discovery channel
mermaid [ __ ] documentary although i'm
pretty sure nobody but your dad thought
israel
mermaids are real i got some scientists
on there they were talking about he
missed the whole
the whole blair witch kind of thing that
happened because it's like in in the
post blair witch world like nobody's
gonna fall for that anymore yeah um you
know what i mean and i don't and people
didn't not everybody fell for it back
then either uh it was probably i don't
know if it was like half and half but a
lot of people did kind of go in going is
this real because i will say that the
two guys that directed this who were
actually uh were film students at the
university of central florida uh not far
from here their names are daniel myrick
and eduardo sanchez
and they were kind of like like i said
they got
into this like right at the exact right
time and they knew exactly how to market
it yeah to make it to just kind of
introduce enough ambiguity that some
people would be like hey maybe this
maybe these people did go in the woods
making a documentary and then they
disappeared
and this is their footage and honestly
as
um kind of like [ __ ] up the editing is
and how like uh lo-fi
the picture is and the sound
and you know they used kind of like
amateurish equipment i kind of feel like
found footage movies nowadays they want
to get that aesthetic but they use like
kind of fancier [ __ ] so it's almost kind
of like fake this isn't fake i mean they
actually did it like really really cheap
and i think in a way that kind of
contributes to
why people thought that maybe there was
a possibility that was real i think they
did a really really good job
you know blurring that line between this
[ __ ] really happened and it's a movie
you know what i'm saying i remember you
know um
uh you know like my little friends and
[ __ ] little melissa and and
just down past christianity these little
goth girls me and my first wife would
hang out with and uh you know they
called them little goth girls we were
all young then when this came out and
they knew it was a movie that was coming
but they were thought that maybe the
movie was based on something that really
happened
you know that there might have been
something to
like it was based on a paranormal case
right kind of like
but we they hadn't seen it yet yeah they
just knew that it was common and they
thought it was going to be something
kind of like amityville horror where it
was supposedly based on something that
happened
that's what that's that was the the idea
but it had like a
like you said it had an online
advertising campaign behind it
and it was uh
kind of like
remember those fake
crime uh
fake [ __ ] crime investigations that
would be online where
you're reading this thing you could
you're sure that this is an actual
real crime that happened but it's
actually a fake would they call that
well this is kind of like and i was
going to say too this almost is kind of
like an arg like what people that's what
people would call it or alternate
reality game if you had an arg yeah when
this thing appeared it was kind of like
the first args it was kind of like an
arg yeah that's pretty much exactly what
this is where where everything uh that
they did about it was engineered to make
this look like a real thing yeah um they
basically i mean and they did they
thought of like some [ __ ] that nowadays
is kind of like you know everybody knows
that but back then in 1999 this was very
i mean even look 1999 for context
youtube wouldn't start for another six
years youtube didn't start till 2005. so
this was way before that like a lot of
people were online but not everybody was
it was still very very much in its
infancy we had forums and discussion
groups right chat rooms yeah
and there were websites because like i
said before this movie came out what the
two what the guys did was they set up a
website that made it look like you know
the blair witch project you know the
blair witch thing was a real legend
which it's not they just made it up um
it's based in it's a real town like
berksville maryland is a real town but
they based it around that and um then
they had a thing where the actors
uh who they had come in who used their
real names in the movie
they
basically had to i believe they had to
sign a contract that said you know for a
year
you can't really like after the movie
comes out you can't like
be really seen you can't be in another
movie you can't do all this other stuff
because they were trying to maintain the
illusion that these people were actually
missing
uh so honestly i was watching something
today about it and i don't know if this
is true or not but this is on the imdb
uh trivia page they said that heather
donahue her mom
got like sympathy cards from people like
thinking that her daughter was really
missing or really dead because they put
up that was one of the things and that
was one of the kind of viral marketing
things that they did was they had this
missing poster with all three of their
faces on it with their actual names
their actual height their actual weight
and they gave them out to people and it
would lead you to this website that had
like all this investigation and it had
stuff about like it had fake interviews
with people it had fake police reports
it had the whole thing so they went all
[ __ ] out
uh to make this and i think like i said
it was really a genius move and i think
that that was one of the things that
just made this become like a huge you
reminded me more about it i remember
melissa michelle would be talking about
this we'd be hanging out up at melissa's
house and she lived in this little
witch's shack she looked like a witch
like a little cute little gothic witch
type chick and she was talking about
this and um
she was getting it confused with um the
bell witch the legend of the bell witch
which is a real legend that is a real
legend from tennessee and she was
telling me about it and i was getting
kind of confused between the two i
thought that maybe the blair witch was
the bell witch just kind of you know
that just had a different word for it
and i was at that time i had read about
the bell which and i thought it was
based upon a poltergeist case knowing
more about the case that case is not as
old as they claim it is it's not as no
it's it's an anachronism in certain ways
so i kind of thought i remember she was
telling me about it and i was like damn
you know and i was like yeah but that
didn't happen in the case that case
stopped you know i i thought i knew more
about
the bell which than i actually did in
99. you know this is before you could
there what you couldn't really even
research off
yeah not really like i said i think a
lot on the internet i think that's kind
of what helped yeah like kind of push
this movie into these massive i mean the
thing about it this movie
cost
pre-production filming edit like not
editing but like uh cost like sixty
thousand dollars and then maybe another
uh bunch in marketing but it came in
under a million dollars easily i think
it was only a half a million all
together that was with marketing this
movie made
250 million dollars yeah
so
i mean
and they it's funny because the two guys
that did it like i said they just you
know they just came out of film school
they had the idea back in 1993 they said
oh let's like make up this witch legend
and then we'll make a movie we'll we'll
like use this kind of cheap ass you know
the stuff that we have because we don't
have a lot of money we'll have these
people go out in the woods and we'll do
like a mockumentary type thing and they
were just they weren't really aiming
that high they basically said well we
wanted to do this kind of thing and
maybe we thought it would get on cable
uh they didn't even they weren't really
even seeing a theatrical release uh they
did actually uh they sent it to sundance
and uh you know the sundance film
festival after they were done editing it
and it was such a big hit at sundance
that artisan studios bought the rights
for a million or whatever and then like
in 1999 in the summer they rolled it out
and they the first two weeks it just
played like limited but it was such a
massive word of mouth hit that and then
it went wide and then it just went all
over i was like i think i don't know if
this uh record has probably been uh you
know surpassed by now but at the time in
italy it was the biggest opening uh us
film ever like in their history
so
i remember that i remember that michelle
knew about this story of this blair
witch story before the movie was even
out
so she must have had been she must have
been seeing stuff online because she
said yeah she mentioned the documentary
there was it's called a documentary
there's a there's a mockumentary it's
called curse of the blair witch okay
they showed it on the sci-fi channel
okay and uh it's been online too yeah
and i and like i said there was a whole
website a dedicated website and
everything was there to maintain the
illusion this was a real thing so they
did actually do a mockumentary which i
think i saw like back in the day i don't
remember if i saw it before or after
that i saw the movie okay because i saw
the movie in the theater so it was
effective
yeah she was believing it yes she was
believing it was very well done and i
will say too that i think the reason
this movie and like i said i i saw it in
the theater i think seeing it in the
theater i didn't
i didn't really believe it was real like
i didn't really have a feeling about it
one way or the other um it was just a
horror movie and you know i was like
yeah let's go see it uh you know a lot
of horror movies came out there your
sixth sense came out uh right around the
same time a stir of echoes came out
right around the same time so i was like
seeing a lot of horror movies so i saw
it in the theater uh didn't really know
if it was real or not i was like doesn't
matter i just you know i like horror
movies so i went to see it i will say
that seeing it in the theater
is a lot
creepier experience because you're kind
of in there with like a bunch of people
and when we watch it because we watched
it on amazon prime
and
when you're in your house unless you
have like a really really good sound
system unless every like every sound in
your house is completely quiet you miss
a lot of the real subtle you know what i
mean because sometimes there's scenes
where they're like in the tent and
they're just like what's that what's
that and like you can't really hear it
all that well in the theater you could
hear it a lot better like you could hear
like people walking around in the woods
like behind their tent and [ __ ] like
that you can't hear it as well at home
uh unless you i mean we have a decent
sound system but i still couldn't hear
it that was there was like other noises
and stuff but so i will say and seeing
it with a group of people
um is definitely better like in this
pitch black kind of thing with no
distractions was like much scarier
re-watching it at home it's not really
scary but i can see
i mean i really like the restraint that
they showed they wanted everything to be
as realistic as possible the two guys
they said we wanted to do something like
they were big into
like in search of and like pair they
said well the reason we wanted to do
this was because we thought [ __ ] like in
search of like paranormal documentaries
were scarier than horror movies yeah
and
yeah so it's like so we wanted to do
something like that but that was
completely realistic
um and and also something where
you know they they sighting movies like
you know jaws and stuff like that where
you don't really see the monster all
that much because you know what you
don't see is like scary than what you do
see now i know that a lot of people
complained uh you know even at the time
i kind of remember people complaining
because i liked this movie at the time i
just you know but people did piss and
moan they were like well you know you
didn't see anything there was no blair
witch there was no nothing
there is actually a little trivial fact
about this where you know the scene
where
uh you know heather and them like run
out of the tent like in the dark and
they're like running through the woods
and she's like what the [ __ ] is that
what the [ __ ] is that
right there there was somebody standing
over like to the left like in a creepy
who was supposed to be like the witch it
was supposed to look like a ghost like
floating
and whoever was holding the camera was
supposed to pan to the left but they
forgot and they never had a chance to
reshoot it so they actually were
supposed to show the witch very briefly
uh but they didn't get the shot so they
never put it there and i just thought
that was like kind of funny it was like
so the witch actually was kind of
supposed to be in there but they just
didn't get around to it i enjoyed the
movie for certain reasons and didn't
enjoy it for others i mean i enjoyed it
i thought it was a damn time capsule you
know seeing those old cars and the old
clothes and
uh the the lingo [ __ ] of how young
people spoke back then and
how cute girls were still kind of
wearing mom jeans a lot of them yeah i
forgot about that there's a lot of [ __ ]
now the footage even though this movie
came out in 1999 and they shot it in
97 it's supposed to be 94. okay because
because obviously you're supposed to
you're supposed to be like
oh we found this footage like these peop
these three people disappeared and
they've been they've been gone for a
year was the heyday of mom jeans yeah
yeah but they were still running around
in 97 98.99 there were some people that
were still out of it they were wearing
those yeah um
it was
other than that uh
i was kind of going in and out of the
movie sometimes i just
kind of mind would start wandering it's
just not that interesting sometimes i'd
focus in on it like you know they're
interviewing the guys who were fishing
they were they were funny there certain
characters will kind of draw you in it's
there it's not a
it's not a it's not a cinema style
feeling at all so it doesn't feel like
you're watching a movie
but i think but that's what they wanted
they wanted it to look exactly like
someone's footage that they found in the
woods but when they do that it's kind of
strange your attention spans yeah i get
that so that's that's why
um and then like um
another thing i didn't really like about
is it got very screamy in certain yeah
places overly screamy
and the girl got more scared than people
actually do get scared if you actually
scare somebody they usually just freeze
they can't accept that
you know what i mean that's something
bad's gonna happen most people don't
really show that much emotion when
they're
[ __ ] real frightened um you know
i've seen people die and watched them
die and they don't really show a whole
lot of damn fear
um it's just like they go out of body
they can't believe it's happening it's
that kind of stuff
so
i saw a down poltergeist scared the [ __ ]
out of me and i wasn't acting like that
and i was a kid but i would freak the
[ __ ] out i mean everybody go inward not
outward you're like
i mean everybody's different too i mean
i have seen people like completely flip
out and lose their [ __ ] and i will stay
on that in that time but it doesn't it
wears off real fast yeah you know what i
mean it's kind of like you reach
overload and you go whoa and then after
that you just kind of
shut down more than [ __ ] you know
what i mean you're like whoa
you go inward
it's so some of it is obviously
acting
you know
although that said i will say that
everybody in this like the main three
actors and all the kind of uh extras
that they had
um
which some of which were actors and some
of which were just random ass people
um
all those people i thought their
performances were good because
they really did seem like real people
you know what i mean they didn't seem to
me like they were acting over much maybe
that's just me but none of them really
seemed like they were acting uh to any
great degree
like nothing stood out to me as oh that
seems fake or
whatever it just it didn't really yeah
you could say that she was overreacting
but
that but it never struck me as like not
genuine
i mean you know what i mean that just
struck me as maybe she just like is
prone to freaking out and [ __ ] like that
because what they did they shot this in
eight days
right
they gave i think the ad that they were
uh that the actors answered they
basically said we want a bunch of actors
with improvisational skills
and they said you guys are gonna go out
in the woods and you know
we're gonna do this horror movie
so the screenplay the original
screenplay was only 35 pages
uh they pretty much said we're just
going to get some actors that know what
they're doing we're going to send them
out in the woods
and they actually did go camp in the
woods
um and then they would leave messages
for them like where like go find a
message at this place like with the gps
this is where your character is at today
uh you know this is what we have to get
accomplished today go um so the actors
shot everything themselves heather had
to learn how to use a camera the other
guy mike already knew how to use one
which was one of the reasons that he got
hired
and they so they basically just kind of
let him go and then the filmmakers
in the middle of the night while the
actors were sleeping would sneak around
their tent hit their tent with sticks
leave [ __ ] out so the actors didn't know
what was gonna happen they didn't know
like when they woke up in the morning
and came out of their tent they weren't
entirely sure what was gonna be there
uh which i think like was pretty
effective because the actors and
sometimes like the filmmakers would like
take some of their food they would do
[ __ ] like that like they just kept
[ __ ] with them because they were
trying to like push them to react in the
way that they would react if this was
real footage
uh so
i think that actually went a long way
like i said i i was really curious to
see this again because i remembered it
being good like i'm not because i know
that there's kind of two camps on this
like some people like really really into
this movie like i've seen um
you know a lot of horror fans that
really like it and then some are just
like that's not scary but
it i will say that it was scarier in
context it was scarier at the time
um just because of that ambiguity and
you hadn't really seen there had been
found footage movies before
but not one done to this
uh kind of degree where there was this
whole like lore around it that was out
like all this supplemental material that
was outside of it like a website and a
documentary and all this other stuff and
this whole thing about oh these people
are actually missing and you couldn't
really find out about that so i think
the ambiguity about it
made it much creepier and i will say too
that seeing in the theater was scarier
as well because you got it was like a
much more sensory experience but i seen
all the supplemental stuff online back
then i probably would have gone and seen
the movie but you know i just kind of
heard about it and i remember kind of
test-tissing it when it first was like
oh no no way
yeah but michelle was into it
she was ready to see it
i laughed you saw it because you didn't
see it she loved it
i mean everybody saw it back then holy
crap that was too you know
at the time i think i might have been
hurting for money and we had to go to
the club it was you know it was just
that simple yeah that kind of [ __ ] you
know now i might have seen it later
because i kind of feel like it was
something i would do because i was broke
ass back then too well i'm still broke
ass but i was broke ass back then too
you're as broke as we used to well no
but um but yeah so what i would do i i
could not i could not afford to go see
movies
like the first run so i had to wait like
a few weeks until it came to the dollar
theater yeah and then i would go see it
in the dollar there
if i wanted to see it so i saw pretty
much everything like four weeks after it
came out uh and this might have been
although i might have actually paid to
see this or somebody took me to see it i
can't really remember
but i did know i saw this in the theater
and i actually enjoyed it quite a bit
i'm a big fan
in horror uh generally if it's done
right uh that not showing [ __ ] is a lot
of times if you know what you're doing
creepier than showing [ __ ] because i
kind of feel like what happened
subsequently
with the found footage genre which is
one reason i'm not a big fan of it
is because now that there's all these
found footage movies
it really strains your credulity why are
these people still filming this why are
they you know why is this still going on
and
they've taken it over the top to a point
where now even found footage movies
still have to have like scary ghosts
popping up in your face and [ __ ] like
that like a more traditional horror
movie
right and whereas this one did not have
that this one really did have this
gritty sense of this is some actual
amateur footage that's just kind of slap
dash together
and you know and they didn't really see
anything supernatural
uh they just saw stuff that was like
suggestive you know what i mean like the
creepy [ __ ] in the woods which if that
really happened to you would be scary as
[ __ ] wouldn't surprise me you might want
to check the dates it wouldn't surprise
me if blair witch project actually gave
birth to stuff like taps and ghost
hunters and all that probably got it
from that you know um
they're happy well you know what there
was some like reality tv on in the 90s
but i it was pretty much like mtv's the
real world i think that had started in
maybe the mid 90s or the late 90s that's
what i'm saying somewhere around there
i'm thinking all that [ __ ] taps ghost
hunters was probably a response to
actually the things like
things like this like blair witch
probably it might have been them
actually going out trying to because i'm
watching this in certain parts there's
kind of like something you'd see off a
[ __ ] ghost tanner's
ghost hunters show it is very much like
that watching it now something kind of
like that so
it wouldn't surprise me if this inspired
those television series
it might have like i said i'd have to
look it up because i can't remember when
that started although and apparently one
of them was called paranormal state
which had this dude i remember that one
yeah and it kind of had an underlying
kind of theme behind it and it tried to
bring in kind of like a lore kind of
like kind of like the way
it was supposedly reality is you know
reality thing you know [ __ ] like taps
even though like the dude who's [ __ ]
the star of the show is just like a
[ __ ] total
[ __ ]
scammer ran off with a bunch of people's
money and just quit the show that type
of deal um but yeah he still has a
following somehow well you know
honestly now he [ __ ] stole this you
can kind of do anything nowadays and
some people will still like yeah and
evidently there were times online where
he just came out and just came out and
right said it came right out and said
that that whole [ __ ] show was a scam
and fraudulent you know
that you know he didn't see anything
paranormal
i mean the difference between this
though is that i mean if you looked hard
enough you could discover that this was
an actual like a fake movie they weren't
trying to they were trying to portray it
as real
for term you know for uh purposes of
like viral marketing which worked
gangbusters yeah but they weren't i
don't think they were necessarily trying
to deceive anybody in that way i don't
know when you're talking about an arg
it's kind of like a fine line because
you do want people to think it's real
but nowadays you know in our post
creepypasta era and all that other kind
of stuff
i think people know that it's not real
but to enjoy it you just pretend that
you think it's real you know what i mean
there's that kind of thing and the
reason why this is called the blair
witch is because of the bell witch the
bell witch was a book kind of like this
movie it was like an arg
that book claims to be old it was pretty
old but not as old i um
it's claiming to be uh it's
very early 1800s i think it's when the
case is supposed to be i mean was it
andrew jackson supposedly shows up at
the scene and yeah
deals with the [ __ ] pull for geist
and
specialists deal with the poltergeist
but i don't think that book was written
in the 1800s somebody else can't i think
somebody did an investigation and tried
to it was more like early 1900s
like i think yeah i thought it was the
yeah i thought it was the 20s or the 30s
or something and they were trying to
make it seem like it was much older so
like i said the whole this has been
going on for a long time yeah and uh and
honestly um when you look up like found
footage like the wikipedia page it
points out and i think i maybe pointed
this out at some point in the past on
one of our shows is that you could argue
that the epistolary novel like dracula
or something like that is kind of a
similar similar idea because they're
trying to like they're doing newspaper
reports and letters and stuff like that
so they're trying to have this veneer of
varus millitude so it's like this is a
real thing that happened and give it
some realism so it's not like a crazy
new idea no and the bell which the bell
witch book
one of the thing is it's like a giveaway
is it claims that andrew jackson shows
up to the scene on a certain date that
date is given well evidently he had a
speech before congress on that day yeah
he was in dc [ __ ] weeks away you know
it took a long time to travel back then
yeah it was like you know he'd have to
yeah
it'd be like a week [ __ ] travel yeah
he couldn't have been there yeah because
there's some people that still believe
that book kind of like eaters of the it
was eaters of the dead which is a good
book
they made that 13th warrior movie based
on it yeah eaters of the dead
that was another one my dad believed he
believed that that was actually i read
the book and i bought i bought into it i
didn't realize that that was a
fictionalized history
yeah and and as i said so so people kind
of feel like nowadays
but yeah it's been going on like forever
uh there's always been entertainment
that was trying to make you believe that
it was real yeah um you know and so it's
not a new phenomenon i will say though
that and i know because somebody's gonna
comment
and i think i brought this up before the
blair witch project was not the first
violent footage movie no uh the first
found footage movie uh pretty much
universally was uh regarding's cannibal
holocaust from 1980 uh which was kind of
similar to this actually it was like a
film crew and they disappeared and you
know they found their footage later and
they looks like they get it that's why
they were killing the animals right
yes yeah i couldn't stand that movie as
soon as that dude [ __ ] stuck that
stick through that caramatti carawadi
thing what do you call that thing
caramundi
what cotton water money that's right
yeah i don't know what kind of animal
that is possum all right he [ __ ]
shoved that thing through that possum in
that pot and i had i was like nope nope
uncool yeah a lot of people well there
is a there is a cut of it uh that has
all the animal cruelty taken out because
a lot of people are like because that's
real yeah it's like it's one thing to
like torture people
yeah on you know but if it had been fake
i don't think anybody would have cared
but yeah so cannibal holocaust generally
considered the first found footage movie
interestingly
there was actually another found footage
movie it was more like a mockumentary
that actually came out a year before the
blair witch project it's called the last
broadcast it came out in 1998 and
interestingly it kind of has the same
thing except it uses a real myth uh the
jersey double
and it's kind of about like guys that go
off in the woods looking for the jersey
devil like to make a mockumentary and
then one of them like murders the other
ones or whatever and then they find
their footage later on now there was
interestingly uh a rumor going around
after the blair witch came out and was
like this massive success that the guys
that made the last broadcast were pissed
and we're gonna sue because they're like
hey that was like our idea
but
uh so that was like a big rumor but then
the guys were like no man it's just like
we're happy that blair witch got really
big and it's like now that blair witch
got really big maybe people will check
out our movie because everybody will say
hey it was another found footage movie
that came out a year before the blair
witch project i actually haven't seen
uh the last broadcast but it's been on
my list for a long time because i'm kind
of curious but yeah so i feel like the
blair witch project coming out in 1999
um yes it some people said well oh it
kicked off the found footage thing which
it kind of did
but i kind of feel like the real big
like explosion in found footage movies
probably didn't happen until paranormal
activity came out which was what 2007
2009 something like that and uh that was
actually that made pretty much all the
money too unlike a really low budget and
that was kind of like
again it was good at suspending
disbelief because it was people who had
been experiencing paranormal activity in
their house just like a regular couple
and they set up cameras all over their
house like to catch the activity
um so there was a reason people were
filming you know it wasn't anything too
crazy and nothing real
over the top happened a paranormal
activity the first one is actually
pretty good but again like blair witch
nothing much really happens but in a way
i kind of like that better because when
you go too far especially when you're
doing found footage which like i said
you know people need to suspend their
disbelief when you're doing found
footage and then you have like every
five seconds like i said some big like
ghost or monster or something like that
like jumping out at people
you know it it doesn't work out as good
uh it i honestly in a lot of times uh
some found footage movies that i've seen
probably didn't even need to be found
footage they could have just made it
like a regular narrative film and it
would have been fine
um
but so i will give the blair witch
project that and paranormal activity is
that
they actually maintained their
believability throughout there was a
reason why [ __ ] was filmed nothing too
crazy happened so there was a thing
where you could
conceivably like think that it was still
real which to me makes it a little bit
creepier than something that has all
this unbelievable
horror movie [ __ ] going on in it and you
know what i mean so
but yeah i do kind of feel like there
were found footage movies after blair
witch but i kind of feel like most of
the ones that people talk about nowadays
like wreck and all that kind of
cloverfield and all that kind of stuff
that came out after paranormal activity
made a bajillion dollars now i will uh i
will note too
that blair witch project had a sequel
that came out in 2000 which was not
found footage and it was called book of
shadows blair witch 2. pretty much
everybody hated it i didn't mind it um i
thought it was okay i haven't seen it in
a long time so it might suck a lot worse
than i'm remembering uh it wasn't found
footage and actually it did something
kind of interesting
in the sense that it was almost it
didn't go meta necessarily but they were
kind of talking about
uh
the theme of it was kind of like the
blurring of uh you know video with
reality type of thing so i think they
did a pretty okay job with that like i
said i haven't seen it in a long time i
remember it being all right a lot of
people hated it though and then in 2016
adam wingard did
essentially a sequel to the blair witch
project which was just called blair
witch and has to do with the heather's
brother
going and looking for her now i haven't
seen that one either although that one i
like adam wingard don't get me wrong but
uh that one hasn't got two greater
reviews either although i will probably
get around to seeing it just because i'm
curious but
honestly i just don't think that
something like this
could be ever replicated nope it was a
thing of its time it was definitely a
thing of its time and that's there's
nothing wrong with that a lot of movies
are like that and if you can't put
yourself back in the mindset of what was
going on in the cultural context at that
time you're not going to find it scary
but i am kind of curious to know if
people that
are you know that weren't even born when
blair witch project came out like do
they find it scary nowadays i guess it
depends because some people find
different things it had to do with the
state of the technology at the time yeah
culture was um
it was the beginning of the internet era
the internet was the wild west it was a
lot better and better in certain ways
today everything's on the internet it's
kind of civilized and
advanced
back in these days the the internet was
still kind of mysterious
uh it was like the wild west you never
could tell what you'd see on on there um
i mean you could [ __ ] go find some
serial killer [ __ ] happening on there
you know like snuff flicks and stuff
stuff that come from eastern europe
soldiers killing each other and
execution videos places
they had them all in places like gore
gallery and it was had a surreal
subversive tone to to to the internet
uh it was it was a time in which you
could buy drugs over the internet
that's how that's how wild it was
um
and then out of nowhere
comes this story of this weird ghost
blair witch project thing and evidently
they had little
documentaries you could watch and the
internet had a creepy tone to it back
then so that really would have built up
the story and and in those days
the right
you know people in their 20s early 20s
would be talking about this and people
in their teens would be talking about it
you know at denny's
i mean it was a big deal everybody saw
this [ __ ] everybody yeah there wasn't as
much
competition for ideas because there
wasn't as much stuff on the internet
back then so it was easy to channel a
large crowd into one single phenomena
for a while
in other words go viral it could go
viral but nowhere near like viral today
it would if something going viral would
take longer
and it would involve
it would still involve certain
subcultures of people like the kids that
hung out at denny's you know uh it's
just
i think you had to be there at that time
yeah
with the old internet and see what they
were seeing and it would juice you up to
see this movie and then you see the
movie then you'd either enjoy it or not
enjoy it
had i been on that train back in those
days i probably would have gone to see
it probably would have enjoyed it
but
we just watched it the other day it was
just like okay
well it doesn't resonate the same it's
not the same uh because like you said
back then there wasn't as much
competition for eyeballs on the internet
so it was easier for everybody to be
talking about it they got in like i said
i don't think they meant to do this at
all but they got in exactly at the right
time for this to just explode and so
they kind of lucked out with the
technology with the way the culture was
at the time
the way marketing was at the time i
remember back in those days everybody
asking me had i seen it and i just got
pissed saying no
and it was always like the kids that
were young yeah did you see blair with
positive you know like 17-18 or did you
see it did nothing see it but
you know i'm [ __ ] 24 i'm grown you
know that kind of [ __ ] i'm 25
[Laughter]
that was kind of what it was well you
know i don't see that [ __ ] man [ __ ] that
[ __ ]
did you see it you know that just you
know just that sounds like some dumb
[ __ ] you would say
but no um
i i just kind of missed it i i don't i
wasn't you had to get on the train early
you had to be waiting for that yeah and
it's not only that but it's just kind of
like and we've talked about this before
with other types of horror movies where
you know one if you didn't see it at the
time like so like the exorcist or
something like that if you didn't see it
at the time or with its cultural context
maybe the exorcist is a bad example
because that's like still a good movie
but there's movies nowadays that were
like the first of their kind and i know
this wasn't the first of its kind it was
like the third but whatever it was the
first one to kind of get really really
popular um you know
this is the first one they saw yeah
movies that were kind of the first of
their kind were real you know on the
vanguard or whatever and then
subsequently so many other ones have
been made like i said 40 bajillion found
footage movies have come out since then
and i feel like younger horror fans have
already seen all of those so going back
and seeing this one it's just gonna seem
like a big fat nothing because it's like
well nothing happens there's no monsters
there's no it's just people lost in the
woods screaming and like some noises
outside a tent and [ __ ] like that yeah
but you know which i get that uh because
found footage has gotten so ubiquitous
and has gotten a lot more like a regular
movie
nowadays and everybody's seen it
everybody knows the tropes back then as
i said it's the same reason why kids in
the 70s probably thought in search of
was creepy which we did yeah and the
movie makers in this who are younger
than us but they uh were still really
into those kind of shows and they
thought they were creepy and the reason
they were creepy is because you weren't
really sure if the [ __ ] was real or not
uh and it wasn't you know music it was
like creepy music it was and it was easy
to like suspend yeah it was easy to
suspend your disbelief because nothing
super crazy was happening yeah uh it was
subtle and so you were just kind of like
oh man is like is this supernatural is
this a serial killer is this what's
going on you know what i mean that's
true does that mean that this and this
could happen you know right
so i do kind of feel like as a cultural
artifact i think it's really like
particularly in the horror genre it's a
really really important film um and it's
a genius piece of marketing just the way
they went about it they were right at
the exact
right place at the exact right time and
you know maybe you had the technology
zillions of dollars yeah um but you know
you wouldn't be able to replicate that
you wouldn't be able to do it again
nowadays you have to do something
different a mainstream hollywood studio
of that era would have never thought to
market it the way that these guys did
that's true yeah because they had a big
because that would have been like
something that little low budget
films well yeah that's exactly what they
did and honestly they did like internet
they did some word of mouth [ __ ] too
like when they went to sundance they had
a whole bunch of those missing posters
printed up and gave them out to people
at sunday it's like these were real
people that were missing and it's like
hey we we have this documentary that we
made about these people and they went
missing and all this other stuff so
there was really a lot of hype about it
beforehand and like i said that was all
down to their really genius like
marketing plan yeah which kind of goes
back to the circus and carnivals yeah
it's really all it is yeah and like i
said it's just i'm i'm not sure how
calculated they were or if this was just
um you know something that occurred to
them and they didn't really think about
how revolutionary it was gonna be
um they didn't seem to they just seemed
like two regular like young film student
guys i think they just went for the
cheaper alternatives and it worked and
it worked yeah and like i said you can't
do you couldn't be you wouldn't be able
to do that anymore like i said everybody
does args nowadays um and everybody's
kind of like savvy to the tropes modern
internet would have [ __ ] pulled the
rug off from underneath this because it
would have gotten out and leaked to what
it was yeah and just and and spoiled the
the buzz
i mean back in the old days the imdb
because we did have imdb in 1999 the
imdb page for the blair witch project
movie
all the actors said uh
missing or presumed dead yeah next to
their names for like a year yeah and
another another this had also been done
you know [ __ ] orson welles did it
with war of the world says radio
broadcast that was another one where
people who knew the deal knew that that
was just a
radio show about a book but other people
kind of came into it because it sounded
like a real news broadcast or kind of
like a news broadcast they bought into
it they thought it was the martian
invasion of the earth
yeah like i said so that's kind of like
an early example of quote-unquote found
footage as well if you didn't know that
that was a story or like a teleplay then
they were trying to make it sound like a
real thing so it's not a new phenomenon
it's just kind of like the format or the
platform that changes the same trick
they just play it different ways right
so yeah so it's not like obviously these
two guys weren't the first ones to think
of let's make something that looks like
a real thing not even in film but in
other mediums it's you know they've been
doing it for them nowadays what they're
doing is that you make a damn video of
put the cat in danger and then rescue
the cat and then get all the likes and
all the money they're doing that [ __ ]
now i can't stand that that's yeah
you've seen that that's terrible yeah
yeah throw the cat in the mud pile and
[ __ ] so it's stuck and then
[ __ ] film it and have your buddy film
you saving the cat oh my god what a
wonderful person
and it's obviously a setup i can't
believe that and they're on [ __ ]
facebook i cannot believe people
don't report those [ __ ] videos or
don't see them for what they are
honestly i don't even like do you
remember there was like a few years back
there was a trend i don't even like this
and this is pretty mild in comparison um
where people would be like hey look how
funny it is that cats are apparently
scared of cucumbers because they look
like snakes or something let's put the
cucumber then this and then the cat will
freak out i'm like please don't scare
your cat yeah please don't traumatize
your cat for the sake of a video please
don't do that it's like that's terrible
it's just like look it's i've scared
pookie accidentally lots of times you
know like i'll kind of sneak up on her
she'll be like well you know what i mean
but it's like don't do it on purpose
just so you can get like a funny video
that's mean yeah poor kitty so that's
all i got to say about blair witch yeah
so uh let us know your thoughts about
blair witch in the comments i know like
i said this one is kind of uh i don't i
don't i don't know if i'd call it
divisive but i know some people are just
like ah nothing happens it's kind of
entertaining it is i i actually was
really interested watching it again but
i can see how if
you know without you know without the
cultural context without the time period
that it came out um and since there been
so many found footage movies since then
it doesn't have the same impact or it
doesn't have the same effect nowadays
that it did back then i lived through
that time and now i understand why
people were talking about it yeah i
understand why why they like they liked
it i see the trick that it pulled well
it didn't quite do that anymore that
doesn't work it does come across as real
footage so i will give it that so um i
think that really works in its favor
yeah but uh yeah all right so that'll do
it for this movie retrospective
we'll see you guys on the next one bye